[Musique]
l'océan abrite dans ses profondeurs des
animaux mystérieux
parmi eux une créature que l'on ne
connaît essentiellement que par des
cadavres le serpent de mer
ces échouages ont permis aux
scientifiques d'étudier l'étrange
anatomie de ce poisson osseux le plus
long du monde
sa tête couronnée d'un poupée de rayon
lui a valu le nom de roi des harengs
plus couramment régalait
mais faute d'avoir pu l'observer vivant
on ignorait presque tout de sa biologie
car aujourd'hui
au large de nos rivages une première
mondiale
une expérience scientifique inédite va
accidentellement permettre à des
plongeurs chevronnés d'observer
d'étudier et de révéler les mœurs
extraordinaires de cette créature
singulière
[Musique]
jusqu'au début du 19e siècle le serpent
de mer appartenait au monstre marin des
créatures légendaires qui hante
l'imaginaire des hommes et les zones
d'ombres des cartes marines
son aspect étonnant sa taille sa rareté
et ses couleurs
ont suscité chez les marins et les
pêcheurs des histoires et superstitions
on l'aurait vu s'attaquer au navire on
la fumait même de redoutable dans qui le
faisait ressembler un reptile marin
[Musique]
au 19e siècle ces dents allaient
progressivement disparaître grâce aux
descriptions des premiers naturalistes
il le classait définitivement parmi les
poissons
pourtant leurs observations sont rares
imprévisibles et dispersés
depuis deux siècles on recense moins de
250 échouages de régalec agonisant mort
ou atrophié sur les côtes tempérés du
monde entier
[Musique]
le plus long jamais recensé
mesurait 11 mètres
récemment par un incroyable concours de
circonstances ce poisson géant aurait
été observé bien vivant en mer
Méditerranée
[Musique]
de la
l'insouciante Côte d'Azur c'est yacht
c'est citadelle
et ses plages de sable fin
plus de 12 millions de baigneurs coûte
chaque année au plaisir des eaux chaudes
de sa mince frange littorale
mais qui pourrait croire que la mise en
place d'un étrange dispositif
scientifique au large de ces plages
ferait resurgir des monstres morts
[Musique]
pourtant la conséquence indirecte d'une
expérience insolite au cœur de l'été
2000 l'Observatoire océanographique de
Villefranche-sur-Mer en collaboration
avec les plus grands organismes
internationaux de recherche spatiale
entreprend de déployer à 60 km au large
de Nice une bouée océanographique
appelée la boussole
son but semble plus poétique que
scientifiques
elle est destinée à acquérir les données
in situ de la couleur de l'eau et les
transmettre ces données vont permettre
de calibrer les satellites qui observent
les océans la couleur de l'eau qui varie
selon les saisons et les lieux est un
bon indicateur de la présence de
plancton ainsi au printemps les algues
microscopiques et leurs prédateurs
abondent on parle de Bloom planctoniques
la chlorophylle des algues donne une
couleur verte à l'eau de mer
ici commence la vaste chaîne alimentaire
des océans
[Musique]
pour connaître l'évolution de la
Méditerranée des observations de la
bouée la boussole doivent être continue
sur plusieurs années
au cœur de ces dispositifs techniques un
biologiste passionné
je suis David Luquet je suis plongeur
scientifique je travaille à
l'observatoire au sénologique de
Villefranche-sur-Mer et je suis
responsable de l'entretien de la bouée
boussole
avec des outils aussi rudimentaires qui
efficaces il intervient que dans les
premiers mètres sur la structure
immergée de la bouée
[Musique]
problème à cet endroit la profondeur
atteint 2500 mètres
un lourd mouillage surmonté de 2 km et
demi de câble en Kevlar doit donc être
déposé
[Musique]
perdu dans l'immensité de l'océan la
bouée sa structure et sa chaîne servent
de point de repère au passager du
courant ligurrovençal
les roues des épaves
les céréales
les poissons pilotes
et enfin les Cerniers
ces poissons vivent dans la zone
phytique c'est à dire les couches d'eau
de faible profondeur suffisamment
exposées à la lumière pour que la
photosynthèse soit possible
tropisme du cône d'ombre de la bouée ils
y trouvent à la fois gîte et couverts
la plupart navigatus certains viennent
se nourrir des algues qui poussent sur
la structure et les plus petits sont
dévorés par les plus grands
d'autres enfants comme les poissons
pilotent se sont spécialisés dans une
activité particulière
la collecte des miettes des repas ou des
parasites des grands prédateurs qui
visitent la bouée
[Musique]
y compris le plus redouté
le grand requin blanc
[Musique]
le squale a été observé uniquement au
printemps près de la surface
décrivant des vastes cercles
concentriques autour de la boussole
[Musique]
une petite population estimée à
seulement 350 requins blancs survit en
Méditerranée
que vient-il chercher ici à 60 km des
plages
certainement d'autres visiteurs de la
bouée comme les tons
[Musique]
mais on ne l'a jamais vu s'y nourrir et
ses séjours sont rares et bref
chaque mois David Satan a des rencontres
imprévues quand il vient entretenir la
bouée
[Musique]
sa mission nettoyer des capteurs
optiques sous marins
le matériel est toujours aussi
rudimentaire mais efficace
solidement arrivé au plongeur pour ne
pas tomber 2500 mètres plus bas
[Musique]
des plongez à risque David est seul
au-dessus du grand bleu sans protection
[Musique]
en moins d'un mois les colonisations par
les algues et les mollusques rendent
totalement inopérant les 20 instruments
de mesure de la bouée
à chaque capteur sa brosse
le nettoyage crée des vibrations des
sons émis dans toutes les directions
des ondes qui sont perçues par les
animaux qui gravitent près de la bouée
elles attisent leur curiosité
or ces sons se propage le long de la
chaîne jusque dans les profondeurs
les poissons ne connaissent pas l'homme
donc ils ne le craignent pas
leur curiosité est réciproque
[Musique]
David sous la bouée c'est l'homme face à
l'inconnu
un jour au mois d'avril lors du Bloom
plantonique l'eau était vraiment très
très trouble je viens de finir mon
travail et je suis descendu inspecter le
bas de la bouée au niveau du câble en
kevlar
et là
j'ai vu un très long ruban argenté qui
est remonté des profondeurs
[Musique]
le roi des harengs
l'ambassadeur des ténèbres en visite à
la frontière de notre monde
pour la première fois au monde un
plongeur nage avec le poisson Mickey
[Musique]
David découvre qu'il nage verticalement
et non horizontalement comme les
serpents de mer des gravures anciennes
[Musique]
étrange
la queue de l'animal est sectionnée
est-ce dû à une rencontre avec le requin
blanc
pour y répondre il faut pouvoir observer
de près les marques de morsure
malheureusement les bulles de David
semblent
[Musique]
cette rencontre accidentelle est trop
brève pour examiner la blessure
après quelques minutes le poisson
couronné retourne dans la zone à faute
c'est profondeurs ou pénètre aussi peu
de lumière que la photosynthèse n'est
plus possible
[Musique]
pour anticiper d'autres rencontres il
faut déjà comprendre comment le régalec
parvient à détecter la bouée dans la
pénombre et l'immensité du courant
liguru provençal
[Musique]
par chance pour David
à des milliers de kilomètres de la bouée
une série d'événements extraordinaires à
les permettre aux scientifiques de
révéler des facettes méconnues de la
biologie du poisson mythique
au Japon le régaler est connu sous
l'étrange non de Riou no tsukai
comprenez le messager du palais des
dieux
en quelques mois divers 2014 plus d'une
douzaine de régalecs de toutes tailles
ont été déposés par les courants marins
sur les rivages du sud du Japon
selon la mythologie japonaise les
messagers du palais des dieux
annonceraient par leurs échoirs
imminente d'un tremblement de terre
[Musique]
ses apparitions infrontues n'ont jamais
pu être corrélés avec l'activité
sismique de la région mais on te fait au
docteur Tyson Roberts le spécialiste
mondial du régalec une opportunité
inespérée pour mener une étude
systématique sur des animaux frais
il mesure 8 mètres
c'est le plus long poisson osseux du
monde avec peut-être le plus petit
cerveau du monde relativement à sa
taille
pour le prouver il va utiliser les
derniers cris de la technologie dans une
clinique vétérinaire
les Japonais ont mis à sa disposition un
appareil d'imagerie par résonance
magnétique ou IRM qui permet d'obtenir
des images en deux ou trois dimensions
d'un corps vivant
cliquez sur une tête de régalette l'IRM
vétérinaire conçu pour des petits
animaux permet de réaliser des images
plus fines qu'avec un IRM humain
indispensable pour isoler le cerveau du
régalec et ses ramifications
j'aimerais en apprendre davantage sur
son cerveau et son système endocrinien
c'est-à-dire comme chez l'homme toutes
les glandes qui sécrètent des hormones
dans le système circulatoire pour la
première fois au monde nous allons
tenter une description exhaustive de
l'anatomie du régalec
les images en IRM confirment l'hypothèse
initiale ce cerveau ne mesure environ
que 2 cm c'est-à-dire la moitié de la
taille de son œil un petit pois dans la
tête voici la taille du cerveau d'un
régalec
paradoxalement il contrôle la plus
longue moelle épinière et le plus long
tube digestif connu chez un poisson
mieux les rayons X d'un scanner du
vétérinaire vont permettre de pénétrer
dans les dédains des structures osseuses
du crâne du régalait et de résoudre une
énigme tenace comment le régaler se
repère-t-il dans le noir des abysses la
plupart des poissons utilise parfois la
vue un peu les sons mais surtout les
auteurs mais chez le régalec ce sens
paraissait absent
[Musique]
j'ai examiné quelque chose comme 35
spécimens de régalec et je n'ai jamais
vu de narines c'est-à-dire la
terminaison du système olfactif
personne n'a jamais évoqué l'existence
de narines ou d'organes olfactif chez le
regalec mais avec ce grand spécimen j'ai
trouvé les narines elles ne sont ni à
l'extérieur ni sur le côté de la tête
elles sont à la pointe de son museau
dans la cavité buccale et peuvent
s'ouvrir sur leur partie antérieure
c'est narines sont donc situées à
l’intérieur de sa gueule aussi pour
repérer des odeurs dans la pénombre de
régalettes doit garder ses mâchoires
entrouvertes et pomper l'eau en
permanence en fait il est probable que
ces deux organes olfactifs ces petites
fentes coniques puissent se fermer
si bien quand les ouvrants et les
ferments l'animal obtienne une
indication sur l'origine des odeurs la
conséquence est surprenante le regalec
est capable de remonter la piste des
odeurs dans l'immensité de l'océan
simplement en effectuant des pirouettes
si vous sentez une effluve mais vous ne
savez pas d'où elle vient vous faites
face à une direction donnée si c'était
fluide est légère vous fermez vos
narines et vous faites face à une autre
direction vous ouvrez ensuite vos
narines et vous tournez votre tête si
l'odeur est plus forte vous êtes sur la
bonne voie vous remontez ainsi la piste
des odeurs en ouvrant et fermant vos
narines c'est une véritable partie de
colin-maillard sous-marine quand ses
yeux ne voient qu'un bleu infini le
régalec et son petit cerveau peuvent
localiser rejoindre et rester autour de
la boussole grâce à une effluve
[Musique]
serait-ce l'odeur de la bouée
celle d'une source de nourriture
ou d'un tout autre parfum émis par une
créature des profondeurs
[Musique]
pour en avoir le cœur net il faut être
capable de plonger jusqu'à la limite de
la zone phytique là où la lumière
s'arrête
David Lucky fait appel à un spécialiste
des plongés profondes en mer
Méditerranée le caméraman italien
Roberto Rinaldi je vais vraiment envie
de rencontrer
en fait je commençais à me sentir un peu
perdu dans la mer
on va être des petits points minuscules
dalles Bleus ça sera vraiment difficile
de rencontrer ces poissons pour le
débusquer l'approcher il envisage
d'utiliser un appareil respiratoire qui
a lit performance et discrétion le
recycleur aujourd'hui qu'un seul
recyclaire on peut plonger profond et
l'autre on va récupérer le mélange bien
sûr qui en respirent mais la chose la
plus importante quand vous filmez un
tueur c'est qu'on fait pas de bulles
avec le recyclaire les poissons ils ont
habitués à tout sauf au bulles
avec les cyclairs on a beaucoup plus de
temps et des chances pour rapprocher les
regalec
en chemin vers la boussole David suggère
de plonger sous une autre bouée voisine
également immergé par 2500 mètres de
fond une bouée météorologique simplement
nommée Côte d'Azur un outil sophistiqué
de mesure des températures de houle et
de vent afin d'alimenter en données les
centres de prévisions
[Musique]
sous ses jupes métalliques cette bâtisse
gémissante semble attirer davantage les
poissons du large que la boussole
ses grincements portent à plusieurs
centaines de mètres dans toutes les
directions
[Musique]
rien n'est laissé au hasard
fini les brèves plongés mensuels à la
boussole
désormais David et Roberto séjournent
plusieurs journées d'affilée près de la
bouée météo en plongeant à tout moment à
commencer par l'aube
ils ont synchronisé leurs revenus avec
le pic printanier de production de
plantes thon donc de protéines animales
ainsi si le régalait est bien étiré par
une source de nourriture d'Orante ou par
les sons de la bouée ils augmentent leur
chance de rencontres
[Musique]
en surface des velelles
ce ne sont pas des méduses mais des
colonies de polypes qui dérivent au gré
des vents et des courants
pour sa première plongée Roberto
s'immerge non pas avec une caméra mais
avec une canne surmontée d'une éponge à
récurer elle est destinée à prélever du
mucus sur la peau du régalec afin
d'effectuer des analyses génétiques
[Musique]
David dans les premiers maîtres avec sa
bouteille d'air Roberto en profondeur en
recycleur
ainsi s'organise la quête méthodique du
serpent argenté
[Musique]
ces créatures serpentiformes ne sont pas
des régalés ni des méduses mais des
salles
des animaux filtreurs de bactéries et de
phytoplancton qui développent leur
chaîne de semblables par reproduction
hermaphrodite
[Musique]
c'est dans cette soupe organique que
Roberto a fait la rencontre de tous les
records
[Musique]
un géant de 5 mètres
le plus grand régalé jamais observé
vivant dans son environnement
le plus long poisson
osseuse jamais recensé en mer
Méditerranée
sa queue n'est pas coupée comme celle de
l'animal observé par David
une chance inespérée à saisir pour le
connaître
avant qu'il ne reparte
[Musique]
pouvoir prélever un échantillon de mucus
Roberto et son recycleur devront miser
sur leur discrétion
et gâcher sur la curiosité du poisson
[Musique]
curiosité du poisson pour l'homme
et pour la bruit
[Musique]
curieusement la peau lisse et sans
écaille durée GALEC semble insensible à
ce contact rugueux
tout contact
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais quand sa curiosité rassasiée le
géant repart dans les profondeurs
imbibé de son précieux mucus le grattoir
est envoyé dans l'alcool pour analyse à
l'Université de Bretagne Occidentale
et Léonore mais eux tente d'extraire
l'ADN du géant et de le comparer aux
rares prélèvement en provenance
d'animaux échoués
il y a très peu de données génétiques
quand même pas mal de choses à apprendre
une étude génétique qui serait basée sur
des spécimens prélevées dans leur milieu
naturel
[Musique]
après pas mal de mise au point technique
on a pu extraire de l'ADN des
échantillons de mucus que l'on a analysé
donc on a trouvé 10% de variations entre
les différents individus de la même
espèce c'est extrêmement fort pour la
séquence ADN que l'on détermine
en fait il semble qu'il y aurait deux
groupes de régalec et il se trouve que
notre échantillon est proche d'un des
deux groupes
ces données semblent conformes aux tests
du docteur Tyson Roberts qui soutient
qu'il n'y a pas une mais deux espèces de
régalec en Méditerranée le régalec
appartiendrait à l'espèce régalécus
glissner présente dans les eaux tempérés
du monde entier dans les eaux chaudes de
l'océan Pacifique c'est l'espèce
régalécus Russell high qui dominerait
des différences morphologiques entre les
deux rois des harengs sont subtils sur
sa couronne glessner possède entre 4 et
7 crêtes de plus que Russell aille
le laboratoire breton s'intéresse moins
à ses débats morphologiques qu'à une
question plus pressante de quoi se
nourrit le régalec en mer Méditerranée
on est en fait partie sur des études de
lipidique à défaut de pouvoir étudier le
contenu de l'estomac d'un prédateur on
s'attache à étudier ce qu'on appelle les
lipides de réserve qui en fait portent
en elle la trace des lipides des proies
malheureusement les études que l'on a
effectuées sur le mucus ne nous ont pas
donné de résultats réellement
satisfaisants idéalement ce dont on
aurait besoin c'est de travailler sur
des vrais tissus de regalec
une mission qui semble impossible
prélever des bouts de nageoire non pas
sur un mais sur plusieurs régales
vivants
autre difficulté même au pic du bloom
planctonique les rencontres restent
aléatoires
quand la météo le permet les plongeurs
effectuent plusieurs plongés par jour
sur l'une ou l'autre des bouées à
différentes saisons les statistiques de
David sont éloquentes
sur plus de 120 plongés à la boussole il
n'a vu que deux fois un régalait
[Musique]
la chance
n'existe pas
les rencontres se préparent se
provoquent
et ce désir
un régalec a répondu à l'appel de la
bouée
et il n'est pas seul
[Musique]
dans l'immensité de l'océan comment ces
poissons du large peuvent-ils se
retrouver ici au même moment
probablement grâce à leur odorat
encore faut-il qu'ils émettent une
substance qui voyage sur de longues
distances au gré des courants
mais quelle serait cette substance
une phéromone c'est-à-dire un produit
chimique produit par un régalec pour
attirer un autre regallec ainsi le
régalec est capable d'envoyer un message
codé uniquement détectable par d'autres
régalesques sur de très longues
distances et quand ils sont proches des
régalettes communiqueraient par le
langage du corps
à quoi lui servent sa crête et ses
grandes nageoires pelviennes
à l'évidence elle ressemble à un
dispositif de signalisation propre pour
régalec les plongeurs vont confirmer son
hypothèse pour être vu par ses
congénères le poisson à la peau miroir
adopte une posture étonnante
la croix
[Musique]
ces postures statiques devraient
permettre à David de l'approcher pour
prélever des tissus
[Musique]
encore faut-il pouvoir nager à son
rythme
et le contraindre à rester près de la
surface
pas si simple
[Musique]
et avec sa petite nageoire qui vibre il
bouge pas le vibre sans arrêt il est
capable d'aller très vite pour l'appeler
poisson piège parce qu'en fait il a
l'habitude
méchante découler comme ça mais il fait
rien il fait pas de mouvement et est-ce
que pour un poisson la vestigalité sera
présente quelque chose
qu'on peut pour les plongeurs descendre
et Thésée mais il risque des accidents
de décompression en remontant trop
rapidement reste une solution
passez en dessous du régalec
[Musique]
au fil des mois David et Roberto
multiplient les plongés et les
prélèvements de nageoire
[Musique]
à chaque retour au port ils envoient les
échantillons au laboratoire brestois
or à l'image du premier régalait
rencontré par David la plupart présente
un corps tronqué
le requin blanc figure naturellement
parmi la liste des suspects cette fois
les plongeurs ont eu l'occasion
d'observer en détail de multiples
cicatrices
[Musique]
le docteur Tyson Roberts
notamment aux multiples animaux échoués
au Japon
je peux créer
undercoslec effectue fréquemment une
série d'autotomie qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire
ça signifie que les regallec sont plus
eux-mêmes
c'est comme un lézard quand il se coupe
la queue la différence près qu'un lézard
ne se coupe la queue qu'à un endroit le
régalec lui peut se couper la partie
postérieure à l'anus à répétition a
commencé par la nageoire caudale et
progressivement se couper des morceaux
supplémentaires des longs des cours de
toutes les tailles
et il peut faire ça d'un coup jusqu'à
l'anus qui est ici
et on peut trouver des regallecs où il
ne reste que ça à la différence du
lézard le regalec n'abandonnerait pas sa
queue pour échapper à un prédateur mais
pour d'autres raisons étonnantes
l'autotomie la sévérité de l'autotomie
le nombre de fois qu'elle est pratiquée
dépend vraiment d'un individu à l'autre
c'est une question d'économie d'énergie
le régalec décide cette métamorphose
vers un corps où il ne conserve que ses
gonades et ses organes vitaux mais c'est
très rare chez les poissons en fait à ce
jour c'est le seul poisson connu qui
pratique ça
pour pouvoir prouver cette hypothèse
révolutionnaire il faudrait observer
cette mutilation volontaire ou retrouver
des morceaux de corps de régalec au fond
des océans autant chercher des arêtes
dans la Vasse des abysses
mais près du village de macératin sur la
côte Est de l'Italie la chance a souri à
un géologue
dans une carrière abandonnée le
professeur Patrick zobronzi vient
d'excaver un curieux fossile déposé au
fond de la mer Adriatique il y a environ
2 millions d'années puis remonter par un
plissement de terrain
[Musique]
connu au monde de regalek fossiles il
s'agit de la partie postérieure du corps
elle est repliée sur elle-même mais nous
pouvons l'ouvrir
[Musique]
le principe de l'autotomie a donc été
gravée dans d'anciens sédiments marins
pour l'éternité
d'autres indices notamment de son
comportement alimentaire pourrait être
apporté par les études lipidiques grâce
aux nageoires collectées par David et
Roberto encore faut-il identifier
maintenant les proies du régalec et donc
leur signature lipidique
là on va poser deux pièges 1 qui va être
en surface pour attraper des larves de
poissons et un autre un peu plus profond
pour attraper des petits crustacés comme
des coupes épaules
[Musique]
comme un phare sous marin la lumière du
piège pique la curiosité du petit peuple
des ténèbres
[Musique]
certains gravitent autour du filet
d'autres viennent d'y trouver refuge
[Musique]
deux jours les pêches sont maigres
mais quand le piège est immergé toute
une nuit les collectes matinales
réservent bien des surprises
ces petites crevettes ne sont autres que
du crime
cette espèce présente en abondance dans
le nord de l'Atlantique ferait briller
ses organes bio lumineux sans dans la
zone aphotique de Méditerranée
mieux après analyse des échantillons à
l'Université de Bretagne occidentale la
signature lipidique de ce krill se
retrouve dans la chair du régalet
or la nuit le kril effectue des
migrations verticales pour s'approcher
de la surface et si nourrir en plancton
ainsi il évite les chasseurs durs comme
la plupart des poissons qui gravitent
autour des bouées
mais dans son sillage il entraîne tous
ses prédateurs dont la vue est adaptée
au très faible lumière parmi eux les
régalec
pour tenter d'observer leur festin les
Aquanautes doivent oser des plonger de
nuit
au large en recycleur sans aucun repère
et au-dessus de 2500 mètres d'apesanteur
il faut vraiment être attentif en a d'un
lois complet et on n'a pas vraiment on
n'a pas de possibilités de solennité
[Musique]
des tranches visiteurs gélatines font
leur apparition dans le noir infini
[Musique]
tel un super organisme ces aliens des
profondeurs remontent ensemble chaque
nuit pour un festin hors norme
[Musique]
c'est la plus grande migration de
biomasse au monde
[Musique]
dans leur piège urticants du krill
signe prometteur
mais où sont passés les poissons les
résidents du jour
[Musique]
il semble craindre de grands prédateurs
invisibles
et se regroupent
[Musique]
idem face au menaces fantômes David et
Roberto se rapprochent
au mieux surveiller dans toutes les
directions
[Musique]
un poisson lune
fausse alerte
comment voler qui rentre dans ce magasin
des jouets avec les faisceaux de lumière
on va révéler des couleurs magnifiques
des colorisants qui ne voit pas le jour
on sait qu'il y en a beaucoup de jouets
partout on ne voit très peu mais c'est
suffisant pour être émerveillé parce
qu'on voit
[Musique]
le poisson roi
dans ses habits de lumière
seules les éclairages sous marins révèle
ses couleurs exubérantes et sa peau
miroir
quoi lui servait-elle dans le noir
absolu
à refléter les lumières du grill pour
mieux s'immiscer parmi ses proies
une énigme d'autant plus insoluble que
le poisson
ignore le cri de
pourtant il détend sa bouche comme pour
attraper des proies invisibles
[Musique]
les éclairages perturberaient donc son
festin
à y regarder de plus près de minuscules
visiteurs semblent aller et venir à leur
gris dans la gueule du régalais
[Musique]
des parasites
ceux-ci sont des parasites externes qui
ne séjournent pas en permanence dans le
corps du régalait
les parasites internes eux permettent de
placer le régalec dans la chaîne
alimentaire en particulier de connaître
ses prédateurs
c'est du moins la vie de doctorants
américaines spécialisé dans l'étude des
parasites de poissons à l'université de
Santa Barbara en Californie ce sont des
contenus stomacaux de Regal exéchoués
qui ont permis à Sarah Weinstein et Anna
Garcia de faire d'étonnant découverte
les parasites offrent un bel aperçu de
la vie du régalec des informations qu'on
ne pourrait pas avoir autrement car ces
parasites ont des cycles complexes en
grandissant à travers plusieurs autres
par exemple on a trouvé au moins trois
espèces de nématodes ça c'est vraiment
intéressant car l'une d'entre elles
ressemble beaucoup à une espèce qui
utilise les mammifères marins comme leur
dernière route
après analyse approfondie l'université
de Santa Barbara a confirmé que la
présence de nématodes juvénile dans les
viscères de régalec apporterait la
preuve que ce poisson est la proie de
prédateurs des profondeurs comme les
cachalots
en effet ces grands c'est assez sont
connus pour être les autres de la même
espèce de nématodes au stade adulte
[Musique]
qui vivent dans les chair du regallec
arrivent avec les proies qu'il consomme
comme le kril or le cri lui apporterait
également ses bactéries bioluminescentes
mais à ce jour aucun organe
bioluminescent n'a été trouvé sur le
regalec ils sont en effet difficilement
détectables sur des poissons morts
les lumières émises par la plupart des
poissons bio luminescents sont si
faibles qu'on ne peut les détecter à
l’œil nu c'est le cas chez le régalec
aussi David et Roberto suggèrent de
remplacer les Landes ordinaires par des
lampes ultraviolettes en abrégé UV qui
révèle la fluorescence des êtres vivants
[Musique]
notamment les leurs lumineux des
mangeurs de crimes
en identifiant les zones fluorescentes
on isole les organes dont la
bioluminescence pourrait être révélés
par une analyse chimique et
microscopique
[Musique]
malheureusement la portée de ses longues
UV dans l'eau et bien moins moindre que
celle des lampes ordinaires qui annulent
leur effet
l'exercice est à la fois dangereux et
difficile
David va devoir repérer le régalet grâce
aux lumières blanches puis les éteindre
et laisser Roberto et ses UV la
prochaine de très près
[Musique]
Paris
osé
Paris gagné les lampes juvées révèlent
deux organes fluorescents sur le crâne
du régalet l'un sous le menton l'autre
sur le front
ces organes pourraient être bioluminés
sans mais seul un examen approfondie sur
des poissons vivants ou agonisants
pourraient le confirmer
tel des pièges lumineux miniatures il
permettrait aux régalec de leur
réciproix
sa beauté peut aussi être fatale pour
les plongeurs
c'est comme ça que j'ai réalisé qu'il en
était en train de descendre à toute
vitesse
et quand j'ai regardé la montre on était
à 71 m
en fait c'était une piège c'est le petit
poisson il m'a amené chez lui dans son
abysse
[Musique]
le serpent de mer n'est plus la créature
mythique qui dévorait les navires
seuls son envoûtant de beauté peut-être
fatal
au plongeur de l'occulté pour mieux dire
le monde du poisson roi
un animal rare inoffensif
et fait
[Musique]
érie
[Rires]
[Musique]